Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin jetzt abends auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, natürlich Frau Doktor.
So als wir Sie ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Kaisa Schulz.
Kaisa Schulz?
Ja.
Herr Kaisa?
Herr Schulz, können Sie Ihren Vornamen und Namen wissen?
K-A-I-S-E-R, Kaisa.
Und S-S-H-U-L-S-T.
U-L-S-T?
Ja.
U-L-S-T. Schulz, okay.
Herr Schulz, wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
74?
Ja.
Okay. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
1. Juni 1951.
1951, okay. Und wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
1 Meter 75.
75, okay. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 85 Kilogramm, bravo, Doktor.
85 Kilogramm, okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Hermula.
Hermula, okay. Vielen Dank für diese Informationen, Herr Schulz.
Gern.
Was ist heute für Sie sonst? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, bravo, Doktor. Ich habe starke Hüste.
Starke Hüste?
Ja.
Okay. Seit wann haben Sie Hüste?
Seit drei Monaten habe ich diese Probleme.
Okay. Könnten Sie Ihre Hüste ein bisschen beschreiben?
Ja.
Kannst du eine Trucke hüsten oder mit Ausruf?
Ich habe auch Ausruf. Besonders morgens.
Wie ist auch Ihr Ausruf?
Weiße, schleimig. Ein bisschen schleimig.
Haben Sie Blut im Ausruf bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Okay, es freut mich. Und haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, natürlich. Ich habe Atemnot.
Ich habe Atemnot. Früher hatte ich Atemnot.
Und Atemnot besteht beim Laufen oder Treppensteigen.
Aber jetzt tritt die Hüste auf Atemnot in Ruhe.
Okay.
Jetzt, ca. drei Monate, haben Sie Hüste in Ruhe?
Haben Sie Atemnot in Ruhe?
Nein, vor einem Monat habe ich Atemnot in Ruhe.
Okay. Haben Sie andere Begleitsenttome, z.B. Fieber?
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor. Nein.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Ja, ich habe Brustschmerzen.
Aber nicht immer.
Wenn ich viele Hüste oder Treppen habe, habe ich Brustschmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie mit Atemnot aufgetreten?
Beim Laufen oder Treppensteigen habe ich vielleicht ein bisschen Brustschmerzen.
Aber in Ruhe habe ich mich vielleicht nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie noch Brustschmerzen?
Nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen die Schwindelung?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen die Übung oder haben Sie Erbrechen?
Übung, Erbrechen, nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ungewöhnlich, ab oder so genommen?
Ich habe immer gleich gewischt.
Ja, es freut mich sehr gut.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nachschweiß? Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay, sehr gut.
Haben Sie früher ein Nr. 5 für diese Bewerber gehabt?
Oder waren Sie bei anderen Arzt für diese Bewerber?
Das war einmalig, aber vor ein Monaten bin ich bei einem Hausarzt gewesen.
Er hat mir eine Hustenmittel verschrieben, aber das ist mir nicht geholfen.
Okay. Ist Ihre Husten immer da oder fühlen Sie sich?
Nicht immer, besonders morgen und nachts.
Wie schlafen Sie gut?
Deswegen ist Husten und Atemnot nicht gut, Doktor.
Okay. Wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie beim Schlafen?
Ich muss mindestens zwei Kissen beim Schlafen brauchen.
Okay. Schnurken Sie?
Schnurken, ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay. Normalerweise liegen Sie lach.
Ich habe nicht bechten, Doktor. Ich habe nicht bechten, da ist nichts.
Entschuldigung. Können Sie lach liegen?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Aber wenn ich laufen oder Treppen steige oder sich bewege, fühle ich mich sehr müde.
Ich bin total erschrocken.
Können Sie flach liegen?
Flach liegen? Ja, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Ist bei Ihnen in Jemen eine blaue Farbe, eine Farbeänderung,
die in der Lippen oder in der Finger aufgefallen ist?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, aber meine Onkel hatten mir gesagt,
ja manchmal habe ich eine blaue Farbe, am Lippen.
Okay. Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Besonders eine Lungenerkrankung?
Ich habe seit Jahren arteriöle Hypertonik.
Noch etwas?
Ja, ich habe eine Bluthochdruck.
Seit 15 Jahren ist es eine Zuckerkrankung.
Vor zwei Jahren war ich bei einem Bürologen.
Er hat mir gesagt, dass meine Vorhersicht etwas vergrößert ist.
Okay.
Ich muss häufig auf die Toilette, aber es kommt eine kleine Menge Unia.
Ja, okay. Ich verstehe. Wie ist Ihr Apathit?
Ich habe kaum Apathit.
Kaum Apathit. Seit wann? Seit drei Monaten?
Seit ungefähr sechs Monaten.
Sechs Monate. Okay.
Wie ist Ihr? Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang auch?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Verstopfung, aber nicht immer.
Aber ich muss oft auf die Toilette gehen.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe eine Zuckerkrankung und eine Prostateprobleme.
Deswegen muss ich oft auf die Toilette gehen.
Auch nachts?
Ja, besonders nachts.
Okay. Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Zotibrennen oder Zahraufstöße?
Nein, ich habe keine.
Okay. Und Sie hatten früher keine Lungenerkrankungen?
Ja, ich hatte früher keine.
Okay. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, natürlich. Ich nehme 15 mg mit Formin.
Einmal morgens, einmal abends, zweimal täglich.
Mit Formin? 15 mg?
Ja, 15 mg mit Formin.
Okay, 15.
Entschuldigung, 500 mg.
Okay. Und morgens?
Ja, morgens und abends. Und Metaprolol, 25 mg einmal.
Und ich habe gesagt, ich nehme ein Hostelmittel ein.
Aber den Namen weiß ich nicht jetzt.
Okay. Noch etwas? Haben Sie eine Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe außerdem ein Wasser-Tablet.
Wasser-Tablet. Ja, ein Wasser-Tablet.
Aber jetzt weiß ich nicht den Namen.
Okay. Haben Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, bei mir wurde mit 30 Jahren eine Kalemblase-Operation durchgeführt.
Vor 30 Jahren? Ja.
Kalemblase? Ja.
Okay. Wissen Sie, haben Sie eine Stein- oder Entzündung?
Ja, ich hatte eine Entzündung.
Entzündung. Okay. Und ruchen Sie?
Ja, leider, Frau Doktor. Ich rauche 25 Zigaretten täglich seit 20 Jahren.
25? 25 Zigaretten täglich.
Seit wann ruchen Sie?
20 Jahren.
20 Jahren. Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke keinen Alkohol. Nein.
Keinen. Okay. Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich habe nicht mit Drogen konsumiert.
Wie wiederholen Sie das?
Ich habe nicht mit Drogen probiert.
Okay. Entschuldigung.
Und treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich fahre manchmal dreimal am Wochenende.
Okay. Sehr gut.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja. Mein Vater hat einen Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Ja, ich habe es gesagt. Okay.
Danke schön. Meine Mutter lebt in Altenheim. Sie hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Und ich habe einen Bruder. Mein Bruder leidet mit Lungenkrebs.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid. Und Sie sind Rentner?
Ja, natürlich.
Was machen Sie früher?
Früher arbeite ich als Lehrer.
Lehrer. Sehr gut. Und leben Sie alleine oder mit Jemanden?
Ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei gesunde Kinder. Ich lebe mit meiner Familie.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Ja, ich reagiere allergisch auf Hausstopp.
Hausstopp. Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ich reagiere auf Renitis und Husten.
Waren Sie letztes Jahr im Ausland?
Nein, ich bin immer in Deutschland.
Herr Schuss, ich habe eine Frage.
Waren Sie plötzlich in diesen Hüsten?
Ja, früher war ich in diesem Haus langsamer.
Langsam. Denken Sie, gibt es eine bessere Auslösung für diese Hüsten?
Ja, besonders auf Belastung.
Besonders bei der Belastung.
Okay.
Herr Schuss, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Wollen Sie etwas sagen?
Fragen Sie mich?
Ja, fragen Sie mich.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Herr Doktor, ich habe gesagt, meine Bruder leiden Lungenkrebs.
Ich habe viel Angst. Ich habe Lungenkrebs.
Herr Schuss, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge sehr gut.
Aber es ist zu früh, etwas zu sagen.
Bitte denken Sie nicht gleich an das Schlimmste.
Ihre Beschwerden können viele Ursachen haben.
Um eine eindeutige Diagnose zu stellen, müssen wir einfach untersuchen.
Ich werde die Körperwerte untersuchen und Blutabnehmen überprüfen.
Dann werde ich weitere Untersuchungen machen.
Ich werde mit meinen Obersprachen sprechen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen etwas Genres sagen.
Aber ich möchte sagen, Krebs ist nicht immer eine erbliche Krankheit.
Deshalb müssen Sie positiv denken.
Okay.
Danke schön, Frau Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie.
Okay. Guten Tag.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt. Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte schön.
Der Patient heißt Kaiser Schuss.
Er ist 74 Jahre alt, 1,75 Meter groß und wiegt 85 Kilogramm.
Herr Schuss hat sich seit drei Monaten mit Auswurf, Schütteln und Disziplinen vorgestellt.
Der Patient berichtete, dass die Beschwerden langsam aufgetreten sind und sich mit der Zeit verschlechtert haben.
Der Patient hat diese Beschwerden vor einem Monat beim Hausarzt aufgesucht und würde eine Hystermittel verschieben.
Die Einnahme dieser Hystermittel war wahrscheinlich eine Mikrolytik.
Sie hat keine Besorgerung gebracht.
Der Patient klagt über auf Fatigue, Sionose am Lippen und besonders bei Belastung Tachycardi.
Die Anamnese ist unaufällig.
Wie können wir sagen, diese Situation? Ich meine Belastung und Atemnot. Fachbegriff bitte.
Der Patient hat eine belastungsabhängige Diszipline, aber er hat jetzt in Ruhe Beschwerden.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Insomnie und Inapathense.
Die Ausruf ist, dass der Patient Gewichtsveränderung hat.
Nein, nein. Ich habe diese Frage gestellt, aber er wurde verneint.
Warum ist das sehr wichtig bei diesen Patienten?
Gewichtsverlust? Der Patient hat keinen Appetit und sie hat Hystermittel.
Diese Beschwerden sprechen für eine Bronchalkarcinom.
Außerdem hat ihr Bruder eine Bronchalkarcinom.
Das ist eine der wichtigsten Risikofaktoren für die Patienten.
Aber er hat keine Gewichtsabnahme.
Er leidet seit 10 Jahren an Arteriellehypertonie und seit 15 Jahren an Diabetes Melutus Typ 2.
Seit 2 Jahren leidet er an Benin-Prostatohyperplasie.
Er leidet regelmäßig mit Formen. 500 mg zweimal täglich, Metoprolol 25 mg morgens.
Er nimmt eine Wassertablette, aber die Name und die Dosierung würden geklärt werden.
Was ist der Fachbericht für Wassertabletten?
Ich glaube eine Diuretika.
Bei den Patienten führt eine Cholesthystöptome vor 30 Jahren aufgrund eines Entzündungs.
Er ist Raucher und seit 20 Jahren raucht er 25 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Alkoholkonsum und Drogenkonsum wurden vernarrt und er fährt besonders am Wochenende Fahrrad.
In der Familienanamnese wurde angegeben, dass sein Vater an einem Joghurtinfarkt verstorben ist.
Seine Mutter hat einen Apoplex erlebt.
Sein Bruder hat eine Branche an der Karschnoe.
Er ist Rentner und früher als Lehrer gearbeitet.
Er ist verheiratet und hat zwei gesunde Kinder. Er lebt mit seiner Familie.
Er ist vollständig geimpft und allergisch gegen den Haustab.
Er hat eine chronische Obstruktiv-Lungen-Krankheit.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kamen Branche an der Karschnoe, Pneumonia und wahrscheinlich eine Typerkulose in Betrach.
Er hat eine Nekotinvorgeschichte.
Er ist starker Raucher.
Ich hatte darauf, ob eine Zianose oder peripherale Ödeme anhand von Händen sind.
Ich habe eine Zianose und ich beurteile sie aus und atme sie ein.
Ich würde ein Festorax beurteilen.
Ich auskultiere Lungen und Herz.
Ich kontrolliere die alle vitalen Parameter von Patienten.
Ich würde Blut abnehmen und die großen Blutbild- und Entzündungsparameter lieben Leber und Herz.
Ich würde eine Blutgasanalyse bestimmen.
Ich würde eine Thorax-Rasen-Ausgabe beurteilen.
Ich würde eine Fernausgabe beurteilen.
Ich würde eine LKG schreiben und die Herzkrankheit ausüben.
Ich würde eine Sprometrie durchführen.
Ich würde eine Sprometrie durchführen, um die Lungenfunktion zu überprüfen.
Um die Lungenfunktion zu überprüfen.
Wenn ich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätige, schlage ich die Therapie vor.
Ich würde die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde die Patienten stabilisieren und die Behandlung optimieren.
Ich werde den Patienten ...
Ich würde eine Antibioteterapie anfangen.
Mit Mikrolidikum.
Ich würde eine inhalative Glykochortkoid anfangen.
Dann ...
Ich würde eine Infra-Lauf-Therapie mit Salbutamol verschieben.
Okay, welches Konzil würde Sie anfangen?
Ich würde eine Phenomenologie anfangen.
Okay, kommt Herzinsuffizienz als Ziphania Diagnose bei diesen Patienten?
Ich würde eine Echokardiographie anfangen.
Okay, könnte Sie bitte eine Echokardiographie aufklären?
Okay, eine Echokardiographie ist eine Ultraschallmethode, um die Herzkrankenhaut zu beurteilen.
Das ist eine noninvasive und strahlungsfreie Untersuchung.
Vor der Untersuchung sollte die Patientin keine Vorbereitung machen.
Der Patient liegt auf der Untersuchung.
Wir beurteilen das Herz mit einem Ultraschallkopf.
Wir tragen eine Gel auf der Haut und bewegen den Kopf auf der Haut.
Die Untersuchung dauert ca. 10-15 Minuten.
Nach der Untersuchung kann der Patient sein ganzes Leben fortsetzen.
Okay, könnte Sie bitte eine Sprometrie aufklären?
Sprometrie ist eine Untersuchung um die Lungenkapazität, Lungenfunktion zu beurteilen.
Der Patient sitzt und die Arzt möchte ausatmen.
Die Arzt möchte ausatmen.
Wir machen eine Klappe für die Nase.
Der Patient benutzt ein Gerät für ein und ausatmen.
Durch das Mundstück sollte der Patient tief einatmen und ausatmen.
Wir beurteilen die Erste.
Ausatmen ist besonders wichtig für die Untersuchung.
Das ist eine noninvasive und strahlungsfreie Untersuchung.
Es ist nicht nötig für diese Untersuchung.
Die Arzt möchte nach der Untersuchung ihr normales Leben fortsetzen.
Ihr Leben wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Herr Arzt, sind Sie da? Haben Sie noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt. Wir haben heute einen neuen Patienten.
Ich möchte Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Es handelt sich um den Herr Kaiser Schulz.
Er ist 85 Kilogramm schwer, 1,75 Meter groß und 74 Jahre alt.
Der Patient stellt sich heute wegen der drei Monate aufgetretenen Husten vor.
Die Husten sind zufolge langsam aufgetreten und im Verlauf der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Außerdem klagt er über weiße, schleimige Schuputungen ohne Blutung.
Der Patient ist unter einer Dyspne.
Der Patient erwähnt, dass die Dyspne früher bei Belastung, aber jetzt in Ruhe aufgetreten ist.
Die Schuputungen sind mit Fatigue, Zyanoz, Amlipen, Tachikardie und Blut und Thoraxen einher.
Die Frage nach dem Bein, Gewichtveränderung, Prexy, Stülpfrost würde verneint.
Die Vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Inabpedenz, Insomnie und Polaküri, besonders nachts.
Sie haben Recht.
Anvor er kranken, nannte er seit 10 Jahren Arteriehypertonie, seit 15 Jahren Diabetes Melitus und seit 2 Jahren Prostat Hyperplasie.
In den 30 Jahren der Patient wurde eine Cholesthystermin durchgeführt.
Er nimmt im Besuch der Medikation Metformin 500 mg morgens und abends zweimal täglich.
Er nimmt einmal täglich 25 mg Metformin und eine Dyspne- und Diuretikum-Dosierung.
Die Dosis und die Dose der Medikamenten und Diuretikum sollten geklaut werden.
Antitucessiva können wir sagen als Fachbegriff.
Der Patient reagiert allergisch auf Hausstopp, die sich mit Rhinitis und Tussis ausübt.
Er rauke seit 20 Jahren 25 Zigaretten täglich.
Er trinkt keinen Alkohol, Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Anfragen, dass der Vater an einem Infarkt gestorben ist.
Er hat eine Apoplexie.
Er ist verheiratet, er ist renta, aber er hat früher als Lehrer gearbeitet.
Er hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Er ist von einem Verdacht auf chronische Obstruktur und pulmonale Erkrankung aus.
Der Patient hat eine typische Symptome.
Die Tussis, der Patient leidet unter, leidet unter, Tussis und Tussis und Symptome.
Er hat eine Belastung und eine Stärkung.
Er ist anstrengend.
Das ist eine Schipristophie.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf auf, Schwellungen besonders am Bein,
Haut verbunden am Lippen und um den Fingernakel und Überwärmung vorliegen.
Außerdem ist der peripherale Arterienpuls und der palpeare Lymphknoten.
Außerdem ist die Oskulthäre Lungen und Herz.
Neben der körperlichen Untersuchung gibt es eine laborunterzuchtende Symptome,
um die Diagnostik der Faszien zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich die grosses Blutbild, SRP, BSG, Lebewerter, Nirenwerter, Herz, Enzyme,
Gerinungsparameter und Tumumarker bestimmen lassen.
Dann würde ich einen Röntgen Thorax veranlassen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
um andere mögliche Lungenprobleme auszuschließen.
Außerdem würde ich einen CT-Destorax veranlassen, um andere mögliche Lungenprobleme auszuschließen.
Dann würde ich einen Spirometer durchführen, das ist Bronchoscopy.
Spirometer, ja.
Spirometer, das ist das, was wir hier sehen.
Außerdem würde ich den Patienten eine EKG schreiben, um mögliche Herzprobleme auszuschließen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten eine EKG schreiben,
um mögliche Herzprobleme auszuschließen.
Sollte sich meine Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Erstens würde ich den Patienten einen venösen Zugang legen.
Danach würde ich den Patienten eine Pulsikaitsuffe und Brankodilatatue und Cortison verbrechen.
Außerdem würde ich den Patienten eine Pneumonologiekonsul anordnen, um meine Unterrapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Danach würde ich den Patienten eine Pulsikaitsuffe verändern.
Zum Beispiel Nikotinkarenz und Alkoholkarenz und Gewichtsreduktion.
Der Patient trinkt keinen Alkohol.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit dieser geplanten Untersuchungen fortsetzen.
Ok, könnten Sie bitte das EKG aufklären?
Ja, ich würde Ihnen das EKG aufklären.
Das EKG ist eine spezielle Untersuchung, mit der wir elektrische Aktivitäten beurteilen.
Diese Untersuchungen helfen uns, die Erkrankungen wie Herzrhythmstörungen, Durchblutstörungen und andere Herzprobleme frühzeitig zu erkennen.
Dazu setzen wir den Patienten eine Elektrode auf den Brust und den Arm und den Bein ein.
Dann wird die Bildung des Gewebes auf einem Monitor gedreht.
Kurve.
Die Untersuchungen dauern etwa 5-10 Minuten. Die Untersuchungen sind schmerzfrei, röntgenstrahlenfrei und ungefährlich.
Es gibt keine spezielle Vorbereitung vor der Untersuchung.
Nach der Untersuchung können die Patienten ihre Altar wie Gewohnheit fortsetzen.
In manchen Fallen können andere Untersuchungen stattdessen durchgeführt werden.
Das ist der Grund für die Erkrankungen.
Vielen Dank. Ich glaube, das ist genug.
Mein Name ist Klover.